this is an advanced git course taught by
tobias gunther he'll teach you some more
advanced concepts and tools to make you
more productive and confident with git
hello free code cam friends my name is
tobias and i'm going to make you a
better git user today if you're using
git as your version control system you
have a lot of powerful stuff available
and we're going to talk about some of
the more advanced topics today cherry
picking interactive rebates sub modules
and much more
at the end of the session you'll be a
lot closer to becoming an advanced git
user
before we start a huge shout out to the
freecodecamp team thank you so much for
being on this mission of teaching people
how to code and thanks for letting me
contribute a little bit
a couple of words about my own
background i am part of the team behind
tower
tower is a git desktop gui for mac and
windows and we've been around for more
than 10 years and helped over a hundred
thousand developers and designer
designers work more easily with git
become more productive with git and make
fewer mistakes
for today's sessions session you do not
need to have tower installed you can
follow along on the command line don't
worry
okay
let's get started
interactive rebase is like the swiss
army knife of git commands lots of use
cases and lots of possibilities it's
really a great addition to any
developer's tool chain
i'll start to explain what you can do
with it and then we'll look at a couple
of practical examples
so in short interactive rebase allows
you to manipulate your commit history
you can make changes to your commits
after the fact
so you could change an old commits
message you can delete commits reorder
them combine multiple commits and even
reopen a commit edit it and make new
changes from it's changed crazy stuff
keep in mind though that interactive
rebase rewrites your commit history so
the commits you manipulate will have new
hash ids technically they are new
commits
and there's a simple rule you shouldn't
use interactive rebase on stuff that
you've already pushed to a shared
repository use it for cleaning up your
local commit history
a good example is when you're done
developing on a feature branch before
you merge it back into a team branch you
can optimize that clean up the commit
structure so it's easier to understand
and that's exactly what interactive
freebase is meant to do
before we take interactive rebase for a
test drive let's look at the general
workflow this is the same no matter what
exactly we're doing deleting a commit
changing a commits message combining
commits the general steps are always the
same
so the first step is to determine which
range of commits you want to manipulate
how far back in time do you want to go
once you have that you can start the
actual interactive rebase session
and finally you'll have to change chance
to make your edits you can manipulate
the selected commits by reordering
deleting combining and so on
okay
let's try this in practice we'll do two
things as examples first we'll change an
old commits message and secondly we'll
combine two old commits into one
all right let's hop into the command
line and take a look at our repository
get log
okay
so let's say we want to change
this commits message here right
just a note as a reminder if it were the
most recent commit we want to change
this one here we could just use git
commit amend to change the commit
message but for anything older than that
for this one this one this one
we really need to use interactive rebase
so the first step for our interactive
rebase determine our base commit
determine how far back in history we
need to go
and this is at least the
parent commit of the one we want to
manipulate so we said we want to change
this here so
at least this one here
i could simply copy the commit hash of
that commit or i can do a little bit of
counting so this is head currently i had
minus one head minus two head minus
three i'll use that
so git rebase
dash interactive head
tilde
three
so there is an editor window popping up
just as i promised let's make this
bigger
and you can see all of the commits that
we just selected
and by selected i mean
that we referred to a range of commits
head to the three three behind the head
from head all the way to the one we
mentioned so we can now manipulate these
commits
but
a big but but we don't change the commit
message right here in this window we
only tell get what kind of manipulation
we want to perform so we just mark up
this line here
with the reword action keyword
that's the action keyword that allows us
to change the commits message and don't
worry all of the action keywords are
protocol or documented here in the
comments
all right
reword then we just save and close the
window we do not make our changes to the
commit message right here right we do
not do that we only mark it up
so save and
close
and that's actually it so now
we get an editor window again why is
that because we can now finally actually
change the commit message so let's make
a change optimize the markup structure
very important
save and close
and
let's
check
git log again
and we can see it's now optimized the
markup structure so we've successfully
changed null commits message
so let's do one more example of an
interactive rebase
let's combine let's take a closer look
let's combine
well let's say
these two
these two commits here into one
again
first step of any interactive rebase
correct we have to determine the base
commit
and again we have to go at least to the
parent
commit so at least this one here so it's
head minus one two three four okay
so get rebase
interactive head and
tail d4
again
here are the commits we just requested
for manipulation and this time we're
using the squash keyword
works by combining the line we mark up
this here
with the one above
so by marking up line number two
with squash it will combine it with line
number one which is what we want right
we want to combine these two commits so
i'll mark up this one with with squash
and combine it with the one before
again we just save and close the window
and a new window will pop up right
why is that because by combining two old
commits we are creating a new one right
and we can give this new commit a commit
a message of course so i'll just write
combine
two into one
and again save and close
and let's see what happened
here on the command line
online
all right now we have combined these two
old commits you can see
they were present here and they are now
combined as one under this commit here
so these were just two examples of what
interactive rebase can do if you want to
see the other possibilities you should
check out our video about undoing
mistakes in kit and i'll add a link in
the description
normally when you integrate commits you
do this on a branch level
you use a command like get merge or get
rebase and integrate all the new commits
from one branch
into your current head branch
and normally that's exactly what you
want
but in some situations
you might only want a specific commit
not all the commits from another branch
and this is where git's cherry picking
tool comes in handy
i'll show you a practical example in a
minute but before that a word of warning
don't get too excited about cherry pick
your main way of integration should
still be on the branch level merge and
rebase were built exactly for this job
cherry picking should only be used for
very special situations you need to have
a good reason to use it it's not a
replacement for merge and rebase
i'll show you i'll show you a great
example for when cherry pick is actually
the right tool to use
let's say you made a commit on the wrong
branch as an example many teams don't
want you to commit directly to main or
master or other long-running branches
and still we forget and commit there by
accident of course
and this is a perfect example for cherry
pick
let's take a look at an example
situation in practice
okay
so
and currently we are on master and have
that checked out and the last commit
says newsletter sign up page okay but we
already have a feature newsletter branch
so my guess is and i'm correct this
should have been here this should have
happened on the feature newsletter
branch
so we want this commit here
to be on the feature branch and not on
master so let's use cherry pick to move
it over
okay
so first we switch to the
feature branch
feature newsletter in that
case and then we cherry pick that commit
over and we can just copy the commit
hash so this is the one we want
to the clipboard and then get cherry
pick and the hash of the commit
and voila let's take a look at what
happened
and we can see
boom here it is now it should have been
here in the first place and finally here
it is if you also want to clean up the
master branch so this doesn't
linger here it shouldn't be here then
you can also do this we can
get
checkout back to master and then get
reset
dash hard head tilde one head tilde one
means one behind the head so we're
effectively deleting this from the
master branch
and
voila master is clean and newsletter
feature newsletter now has that
brand that commits sorry
voila as if nothing had happened
let's talk a bit about a very special
git tool the ref log
you can think of the ref log as git's
diary it's a journal where git logs
every movement of the head pointer so
what is a movement of the head pointer
exactly that's when you commit check out
merge rebase cherry pick reset
all of the more interesting actions are
documented there
and this makes it perfect for those
situations where things go wrong
let me show you a perfect use case for
the ref log
let's say we don't want these two newest
commits here
at least we think we don't want them
anymore and to get rid of those we'll
perform a reset right they've
disappeared from the commit history and
a while later we noticed that this was a
horrible mistake we've just lost
valuable commits
so let's have some fun and make this
horrible mistake in practice
um all right so
here we go
let's say we want to throw away these
two commits and get rid of them
so we are making this here our latest
revision on the branch
i just copy the commit hash here to the
clipboard
and on the command line i can
get reset dash
hard
and use this commit hash
all right let's
have a look what happened
and we can see
those newer commits disappeared
and we're back at this revision here
i'll give you a couple of seconds to
realize that this was a horrible mistake
panic emojicon
and there was invaluable data in those
commits and we just deleted them by
accident
so let's see if the ref log can help us
in this situation
opening the ref log is as easy as typing
git ref log on the command line
and this here is the refloc that journal
where git logs all of the important
actions first of all the entries are
ordered chronologically which means the
most recent the newest items are at the
top and if you look closely you'll find
this
catastrophic reset action right at the
top we just did that 20 seconds ago
so the journal seems to work
good news
now if we want to undo our last action
we can simply restore the state before
which is also documented here we can
just copy the commit hash this is the
state before
i'll copy that to the command line to
the clipboard
and
i could use git reset once more totally
valid but i'm going to create a new
branch which i find a little bit more
elegant happy ending
and i will have it start at that
previous revision with the correct state
so let's use that let's see what
happened okay there's a new branch
that con that contains the seemingly
lost commits
we just saved our next awesome so we
just restored some deleted commits with
the refloc and here's another great use
case for the reflog
restoring branches
so again we think we can clean up and
delete something and this time it's a
branch not commits but again as life
sometimes goes we realize that it was a
bad idea and we still need it
so let's take a look at this
scenario in practice
um
that is
reflog
recover
branch
okay
so
here's a beautiful beautiful feature
login branch
um but let's say our customer or boss or
team lead
say they don't want it anymore it's not
necessary so
of course we go ahead and delete it
and just to make things worth worse this
commit here this one is present nowhere
else so we are definitely going to lose
data when we delete it
all right but before we can delete it we
need to step away from that branch it's
currently the head branch at the moment
and we can't delete the head branching
git so we're checking out master and
then we can delete we have to force
delete it because it contains
a commit that is not merged into any
other branch
and voila
okay
so
now let's say our customer changed their
mind again the feature is necessary
after all so what do we do what do we do
what do we do
let's take another look at the ref log
all right
and it turns out we're lucky the last
entry was when we made that check out to
master so let's try returning to the
state before again
and i will copy the so here is the
checkout and i'll copy
this here to the clipboard
and
get let me put that on top
get branch i think it was called feature
login if i'm right and we want to have
it start at that
revision here that we just copied from
the
reflog
and let's see what happened
so
okay a branch is back
voila and it includes that seemingly
lost commit that valuable commit
another happy ending
if you're using git in a desktop gui
like tower like what you're seeing here
undoing a mistake is really easy you can
simply press command z to undo your last
action just like in a text editor when
you made a typo and this works for
almost anything accidentally deleting
branches commits files undoing a commit
or a bad merge you might have pushed
something too early doesn't matter what
it is so i can just
go ahead and delete this one more time
delete
force delete i can just press command z
and again there it is
very helpful
pretty often in a project you want to
include libraries or other third-party
code
and you can go the manual way download
the code copy the files into your
project and commit the new files into
your projects git repository this is a
valid report approach but it's not the
cleanest one
if you simply throw those library files
into your project you're inviting a
couple of problems
first you're mixing external code with
your own unique project files but the
library is actually a project of itself
and it should be kept separate from your
own work
there's no need to keep these files in
the same version control context as your
project
and secondly should the library change
because bugs were fixed or new features
added
you'll have a hard time updating the
library code again we need to download
the raw files and replace the old items
these are quite common problems in
everyday projects so git has a solution
and that's sub-modules
a sub-module is just a standard git
repository the only specialty is that
it's nested inside another apparent
repository
a submodule is a fully functional git
repository you can modify files commit
pull push
from inside it like with any other
repository
let's see how some modules work in
practice
all right so
we have a little sample project here
and let's say we want to add some
third-party code
creating a lib or a vendor folder is a
good idea so that it's cleanly separated
from our own files
let's do that
so let's create
lib
and change into that folder and i will
add a little javascript library from
github i can do that with the git
submodule
add
command and then provide the remote url
of that repository
and you can see that the command starts
to clone the git repository responsive
we specified let's see what happened in
our working copy folder
and here we go we have a lib folder i
just created that
and here it is our
project now contains that third-party
library inside the lib folder you can
see there's a dot git subfolder here
so this is indeed a fully featured git
repository
and let me emphasize this again
the actual contents of that submodule
they're not stored in our parent
repository right this is important to
understand a parent repo only stores the
submodule's remote url the local path
inside the main project and the checked
out revision
of course the submodules working files
are here in our project now after all we
want to use the library's code but the
files aren't are not part of our parent
project's git repository they're not
part of that version control context
okay so let's take a closer look at what
else happened
so there's a new git modules file here
so let's take a look at that
get modules
and so you can see here is the path in
our project and the remote url
documented and there's
also a record of that in the get slash
config file
at the bottom sub module lib to progress
again
and finally the git also keeps a copy of
each submodule's git repository in its
internal git modules folder so
here is the git repository
there is
modules and now we have lip to progress
so this is the git repository of our
library
stored inside of our main
git repository these are all internal
files so please don't mess with this
configuration
because
as you can see git internal gets
internal management of sub modules is
quite complex there's good modules there
is dot git config there is dot git
modules my strong recommendation is
don't mess with sub module configuration
values and and files manually do
yourself a favor and always use um
proper get commands or get desktop gui
to manage sub modules
all right so let's have a look at our
projects status
and you can see that git regards adding
a sub module as a modification like any
other so this means we have to commit it
to our main repository
let me just
do that quickly so git commit
dash m
add to project
to progress library okay we've
successfully added a sub-module to our
main project congrats
now let's start from the other end let's
clone a project that already has
sub-modules added
and let's step out of that
and
get clone i will clone the apache
airflow
project for that
and let's see what happens here
so i know this project has several
submodules added and we'll take a look
at those in a second okay
um
all right
here we go the airflow project um
so um
let's see so i know that the project has
some sub-modules in the dot github
actions folder so these are all
sub-modules for this project but if we
take a closer look after cloning
these are all empty
okay so
what's happening here why why are those
submodule folders empty
well you already know that a project
repo does not contain its submodules
files right the parent repository only
saves the submodule configurations
so when we clone a project with the
default git clone command like i just
did then we only download the project
itself with the configuration the
submodule photos however they stay empty
now we can repair that
by now calling
git sub module
update
and we have to initialize these for the
first time and we want to do this
recursively
sorry i have to step into the airflow
project folder and now
you can see there's action happening
here it's
several cloning processes start
and
now the submodule folders have been
populated or in other words the
submodule git repositories have been
cloned you can take another look at that
and see well yeah these are all
populated now right there's files in
here
um
let me see
so using git clone like we just did and
then an extra command is a bit
unnecessary i would say so you can
achieve the same if you use a particular
option with git clone
the recurs submodules option this tells
git to initialize all submodules when
the cloning is finished automatically so
i would have used a command like this
instead right we left that
option here out the recurse submodules
and we would include that now and
everything works from the beginning
all right
um
i don't want to go
into too much detail about sub modules
but one more thing is important to
understand
the way revisions are checked out in a
submodule
a git repository can have countless
committed reversion revisions but the
files from one specific revision
can be in your working directory at one
time right
so in a
normal git repository you check out a
branch
and automatically the last commit in
that branch is your checked out revision
if you add new commits to that branch
the checked out revision is all always
automatically the newest commit right we
just move the pointer forwards to the
latest commit like like you can see here
sub module repositories on the other
hand are always checked out on a
specific commit not a branch
and it makes sense think about it the
contents of a branch can change over
time when new commits arrive
in a submodule however you don't
necessarily want that sub modules are
mostly library code and in that
situation i want the guarantee that i
always have a specific revision of the
code
even if the maintainer of the library
ships some genius updates i don't know
if those would break my code
so i always want a specific chosen
version checked out
all right let's quickly hop into the
submodules in this project
and i can show you that
so
this is the tower git client and when i
select the submodule here so here you
can see that this sub module is not
checked out on a branch but on a
specific revision
this is what i meant
i've already mentioned it managing sub
modules is a bit complicated i can
really recommend taking a look at a good
desktop gui like tower for example
so adding updating moving submodules all
of that is really simple here take a
look and see if it's helpful
okay we could talk for hours about sub
modules but i think this should be a
good introduction just try them out in
your project and take it from there
a git repository is a perfect log of all
your activities in a project every
change is documented and sometimes you
want to browse through this log because
you're looking for something you want to
find a piece of information
so let's talk a bit about how searching
and finding in git works
or in other words how you can filter
your commit history
you can filter by almost anything by
date by message by author by file by
branch even
so let's start with
date and search for all commits that
happened after a specific date for
example
we're doing this in the ruby on rails
open source repository so there are a
couple of commits present
you can use git log and then the after
flag so now i get all of the commits
that are after
july 1st i specif specified
in that repository
i can also combine that with before
and thereby get all of the commits that
are between
july 1st and july 5th
pretty easy
and if you want to search for a certain
commit message you can also do that
you can do that with the
grep
flag and let's search for anything that
contains refactor in its message
and you will see here is one here's one
and there's lots of others
you can get really fancy with grep
because it accepts regular expressions
so actually no limits to your creativity
looking for a certain author works
exactly the same using the author flag
so get log
let's search for anything from
a certain
heinemeyer
colleague
and of course before i forget that you
can combine these criteria of course so
for example you could use dash author
and dash before in combination to find
all commits from a certain person before
a certain date
and then you can also search for files
this can be really handy to understand
how a certain file evolved over time for
example when you know that a certain
file used to work fine in the past
but it doesn't anymore and you can
filter for commits with only that file
so let's do that git log double dash
i'll explain that
readme dot mark down
sorry mark done
and i get all of the commits were
readme.markdown was manipulated
the double dashes in that command if you
take another look
um
they're just to make sure that git
doesn't confuse the file name with a
branch name right
and uh finally pretty helpful uh way to
see commits that are not in one branch
but in another one
so very handy if you want to find out
for example what happened in the main
branch let's say
after you branched off with your private
feature branch
let's type kit log
feature
login
dash dash or sorry dot double dot
notation
main
this will show you all commits that are
in main
but not in feature login and you might
then decide to do a merge so that you're
up to date again or you can at least see
what happened in maine while you were
gone in your future work
all right so much for today
be sure to check out my little advanced
git kit it's completely free of charge
uh it's a little collection of short
videos about a lot of advanced git
topics from things like interactive
rebase all the way to branching
strategies merge conflicts
sub modules what have you it's really
helpful if you want to become more
productive with git and version control
and again it's free
alright have fun and see you soon here
on the free code camp youtube channel